elle a fière allure l'église de pont
c'est sur lignon quatre ans de travaux
lui ont rendu sa magnificence
ce qui attire l'oeil c'est d'abord sa
toiture tout en pierre des laves
parfaitement ajustée en une succession
de lignes droites et de courbes
l'édifice construit entre 1785 et 1788
données en 2015 de sérieux signes de
fatigue qui avaient des chutes de
pierres donc le temps avait donc noirci
les façades aussi mais le plus important
c'était donc ces infiltrations au niveau
du coeur une restauration à ubi cent
mille euros
beaucoup trop coûteuse pour ce village
de seulement 85 habitants
la direction régionale des affaires
culturelles la fondation du patrimoine
l'état
le conseil départemental ont aidé la
commune à réunir les fonds nécessaires
pour remettre en état
l'église saint martin tous les habitants
ils sont très attachés et donc on ne
pouvait pas passer à côté de cette
restauration enfants du village
eliane lépine avait à coeur peut être
plus encore que tout le monde de voir
les travaux commencer et surtout
terminer il ya des nuits où j'ai pas
dormi parce que je me disais ce qu'on va
réussir ce qu'ils vont réussir c'est ces
entreprises à restaurer ce bâtiment 1
un bâtiment à l'architecturé audacieuse
conçu par deux ingénieurs des ponts et
chaussées emiland gauthey et pierre-jean
guillemot un plan en croix grecque et à
l'intérieur une neuve circulaire
regardez cette
paul unique en bourgogne
aucune consolidation apparente des arcs
cintrée et une solide maçonnerie
dissimulés dans les murs supporter le
poids de la voûte dont la structure n'a
aucun secret pour madame le maire alors
là vous pouvez apercevoir donc le dôme
qui est qui et fait donc en tuf
recouvert de deux tailles de lave qui
servent à près de calage pour pour
l'élève
ce sont des lave qui viennent de
pompignan dans le gard il fallait
qu'elles respectent le cahier des
charges donc une pierre calcaire non
gélives et donc voilà est celle ci était
appropriée donc pour notre
église eliane lépine a été de toutes les
réunions de chantier une par mois
pendant quatre ans jusqu'à la pose de la
dernière lave le dernier jour du mois
d'août 2010 9 l'église restaurée a été
inaugurée lors des journées du
patrimoine le 21 septembre 2019
caché dans une cavité de la toiture un
parchemin donne rendez-vous dans 300 ans
à ceux qui à leur tour peut-être
donneront un nouveau coup de jeune à
l'édifice